hey
we are back with the dimensionality
reduction series
in our last video of the series we
talked about one way to escape the curse
of
dimensionality
through an older algorithm called pca
today we will talk about a newer and
very popular dimensionality reduction
algorithm called
umap pca and umap are very different
pca factorizes a matrix characterizing
the data
which puts it into company with
algorithms like nmf
or svd but you map like disney
if you know it builds a neighbor graph
in the original
space of the data and tries to find a
similar graph in
lower dimensions but how does it do it
umap
stands for uniform manifold
approximation and
projection this sounds intimidating
and the paper behind youmap can be even
more intimidating but do not worry
because we break it down for you
the two steps of umap are high
dimensional graph constructions and
it's mapping to a lower dimensional
graph
the construction of this high
dimensional graph is what makes umap so
special compared to its competitors
since it's hard to do it right and fast
and the cool part about
umap is that its steps are
mathematically proven to work
so first there was the data in the high
dimensions and we want to approximate
its
shape or topology each data point is a
so-called zero simplex and a certain
theorem ensures that the shape of the
data
can be approximated when we connect
these
zero simplices which are our data points
with their neighboring data points
forming one
or two or higher dimensional
simplices and with this we can
approximate the topology
so all what we need to do is to make
these connections for this the
u-map algorithm extends a radius around
each point and makes a connection
between each point and its neighbors
with intersecting radii so far the radii
are equal
but remember we want to approximate the
shape of the data so
we want a connected graph containing all
our data points
but this wish of ours brings in two
problems firstly
it often happens that in the data there
are larger gaps where there is
no next point to connect to in the graph
this happens usually in low density
regions secondly there are often high
density regions where there are a lot of
neighbors in the given radius and
everything
is way too connected this second problem
gets even worse with the curse of
dimensionality where
in high dimensional spaces the distances
between points become
more and more similar okay then so if we
have these two problems
with a fixed radius then let's use a
variable radius instead
this choice is also mathematically
supported by the definition
of a romanian metric on the manifold but
do not worry about that just keep in
mind that there is math proving that the
choice of a variable radius does not
cause any
trouble so now the radius is greater in
low
density regions and smaller in high
density regions
but u-map does not estimate density
directly as a number but
uses a proxy the density is estimated to
be higher when the k-th
nearest neighbor is close and lower
when the k-th nearest neighbor is far
away
notice that this k in k nearest neighbor
is a hyper parameter that we need to
choose because with its help umap makes
a density estimation to find the right
local radius if k is big then
more global structure is preserved if k
is small then the radius decreases and
the local structure is more preserved so
the right k
could give the perfect balance between
local and global structure preservation
but there are rarely
any recipes for finding the optimum
automatically some trial and error is
required since
k depends on each data set individually
but
not all k nearest neighbors are equal
since each have different distances from
the point we are looking at
then the connections between each point
and their neighbors get a weight
a connection probability where points
which are far away
are weighted less and lower connection
probability
now that this high dimensional graph is
constructed it is ready to be projected
to lower dimensions
this graph projection algorithm is too
much for miss coffee bean to explain in
detail in this video but
you can imagine this projection as
taking the high dimensional graph
with their edges as being springs where
each spring is stronger as the edge
probability
increases which means that points
connected by
high weighted edges are more likely to
stay together in the lower dimensional
space because the spring
holds these points together and perhaps
interesting to notice is that these
spring forces are rotationally symmetric
which leads to clusters sometimes
landing on one side after
one new map run and on the other side
after another projection
so umap has two main strengths over the
famous graph based dimensionality
reduction technique called disney
it is faster due to its optimizations
and strong mathematical foundations
and it has also a better balance between
locality and globality in clustering
take for example this visualization from
the awesome blog from google pair linked
below
we have this mammoth in 3d on the left
and we can see side by side how umap and
disney map these 3d mammoths into two
dimensions we can play around with the
number of neighbors taken into account
when constructing the high dimensional
graph
and we can clearly see how low numbers
focus on the local structure
while higher numbers more on the global
structure
the minimum distance parameter allows to
specify how
tightly the algorithm will map points
into the target low dimensional space
a high minimum distance will spread the
points more
but it is important to notice that a
stepwise change of these two parameters
continuously changes the umap result
disney on the other side is not that
great in this aspect
because when changing the parameter of
this knee disney's result completely
changes
we really recommend you to play around
yourself with all examples in this blog
post
so far we have seen examples where umap
maps from 3d to 2d
but the visualizations we have seen so
far are toy examples they're just for us
to get an intuition
about the inner workings of the umap
dimensionality reduction algorithm
what umap excels at is reducing from
a lot of dimensions here is a real world
example of 764 dimensional mnist data
containing handwritten digits
it could be nice if we could reduce
their dimensions to
two or three dimensions so we can
visualize this pixel space the digits
are living in
for this we can write a little python
code to load the mnist data
to load the umap package for
dimensionality reduction
and a visualization package of your
liking we like baby plots and you will
see why
we read in the data and we see we have
60 000
training instances of 28 times 28 pixels
which are together the 784
dimensions we plan to reduce from for
reducing we fit and apply the umap
algorithm and we do it once for two
dimensions
and again for three dimensions we
reduced
to 2d and 3d to show you what the cool
thing baby plots can do
it takes both the 3d and 2d embedding
and can animate a transition between the
two
how cool is that hereby we can see that
umap could already cluster almost
all handwritten digits together meaning
that umap here worked as an unsupervised
clustering algorithm
also we can see how useful a 3d
visualization can be over just 2d
where more complicated structures and
relations can be visualized
if you want to visualize these things in
3d yourself
in either r javascript or python and
load your interactive 3d plots into a
powerpoint presentation to show to
everybody
check out the babyplot's website this
was it from miss coffeebean
read the paper if you're interested in
the mathematical theory
and proofs behind you map find it linked
in the description below
or watch the first author of the yuma
paper presenting his umap invention
linked below now go and reduce your
dimensions with umap